and minimalists
all right as previously mentioned you're
in for quite a night middlemost about to
come up here but in the meantime it's a
song that you may recognize
[Music]
if you little thing you think that you
need every little things you think that
you need every little thing that's just
feeding you greed or I bet that you'd be
fine without it
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every two things you gotta
oh that you reach full and all that you
grab or bet that she'll be fine without
it
won't you
so tears way
dear
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
every little thing sparkles and shines
every little thing sparkles and shines
striving you sweetly I do mind oh I bet
this she'd be fine without it
[Music]
so tears away 14
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Canyon City oh
thank you so much live from the iron
City theater
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Millburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists live at Birmingham
Alabama someone who lives in a radio
interview and someone was asking me like
well what's the event going to be like
and I I saw this video Ryan where there
was this giant snake it had to be
somewhere in northern Florida anyone
from northern Florida here tonight it
was a giant snake and it was swallowing
this alligator and this isn't going to
be anything like that we have a special
guest with us here tonight we wanted to
talk about money in minimalism and Ryan
and I have a few things that have helped
us in our own lives with respect to both
of those topics and integrating them
into our own lives but we want to bring
some experts on the road with us this
time around so we're gonna walk into
stage a a guest expert today and so
he'll help us in answering some of these
questions you might know him as the
author of five mistakes you can't afford
to make in college we're gonna talk a
little bit about some of those mistakes
we're gonna talk about money we're gonna
talk about his journey and then we're
gonna talk most importantly about you
all well we're gonna answer your
questions ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to stage Anthony O'Neill
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so so Anthony where'd you grow
up who I grew up in San Diego California
and North Carolina so my biological
parents they really liked each other and
decided to have me but just didn't get
married so uh yeah I split it Cali North
Carolina some of them will get that
later on and you're in you're in
Nashville these days yes sir
and you have an interesting story
because well I mean it almost sounds
like it sounds terrifying you were broke
but also there was a point in time when
you were homeless and you made some some
obvious mistakes in your life with
respect to decisions but also with
respect to decisions with money can you
talk about some of those mistakes that
you've made early on in your life yeah
sure do we have two hours all right I
mean but very quickly Josh you know I
was 18 years old just graduated high
school went out to Long Beach State
University there in LA Long Beach area
and I really wanted to just be me I
really wanted to be this grown man I
wanted to impress all the ladies I
wanted to look good which I do look good
but anyways and so I remember this like
it was yesterday
it's young lady I first ever tried to
talk to she told me I do not date broke
men see see she was like I said dad to
look guys and so when she said that I
was like all right bet cool yeah I'm
broke but I'm I'm a bassist right now so
within a matter of six months you know
man I went out there applied for every
single credit card I could apply for
every single student loan that I could
and I remember the very first credit
card that I got man you know I have a
real mother who happens to be a very
real mother and she told me do not get
this credit card you do not need it
Anthony and within a matter of 13 hours
my first credit card of $500 I maxed it
out the first hour I spent $150 at Red
Lobster trying to treat this young lady
out to dinner
I love those biscuits though man hey man
the biscuits I can't even stand him
right now brother that's two dollars
right there can't do that way I had
enough of those and paid interest on
biscuits that's nasty they like the next
like three hours I spent $150 on two
dozen of red roses there's two boxes of
chocolate some balloons and teddy bears
and then back then in those days in the
early 2000s I don't know if it's still
relevant now because I haven't bought a
purse in years but I bought a donee in
Berks DB purse and I was like 200 bucks
my credit card limit was only $500 I
spent $500 in a matter of 13 hours and
so make a long story short I did exactly
what the average American person does I
make the small little minimum payment
the company sends me back a letter and
says hey eh oh thank you so much making
your first payment on time we see that
you're in college and you can use some
more money
so we've upped your limit from 500 to a
thousand dollars enjoy that is so nice
of them it wasn't it and I said I'm
going to enjoy this thing right now 45
minutes it's maxed out man I wouldn't
put a $500 sound system in the back of a
black-on-black 1987 Nissan Maxima wait
wait wait wait wait and it could even go
and reverse the cars is only worth
$2,000 on paper and it has a $500 sound
system in it so it within a matter of
six months man I wouldn't put $15,000 on
a credit card took out ten thousand
dollars in student loans when I didn't
even need ten thousand dollars because I
was on a scholarship and my father's GI
Bill and then put another ten thousand
dollars on furniture bills so I'm 19
years old get kicked out of college for
participating in hazing which I totally
disagree with when I get kicked out of
college you know my mom and dad was like
no you said you're a grown man so you're
gonna fix this issue yourself because a
grown man doesn't come home and I was
like cool no problem I'm a grown man I
caught all my friends caught all my
family that I thought were my family and
friends no one accepted me in
I'm 19 sleeping in a Walmart parking lot
off of highway 76 in Oceanside
California for a long period of my life
simply because I tried to have the
American Dream impress everyone look
like everyone and it ended me up in the
back of my car you know we were
backstage talking about I built my first
house when I was 22 years old and of
course the first thing that you feel
like doing when you buy this you build
this oversized house is because I had
the three there's only two peoples me
and my wife three bedrooms three
bathrooms full basement two living rooms
what the hell am I gonna do with two
living room right but you feel compelled
to fill every inch of space in the home
in the same thing seemed to be true with
this credit card you're like I didn't
know I needed $500 but now that I have
well I have the appearance of $500 I
have to fill this this credit card and
so we tend to expand we expand into what
our needs or when our perceived means
are at the time and that becomes this
dangerous trap I mean the average
American has over 16 thousand dollars in
credit cards and at one point I had 14
credit cards in my wallet one that 1 out
of 10 Americans has 10 or more active
credit cards and so we're just actively
amassing by the way we're spending on
stuff we don't need right we've been 1.2
trillion dollars a year on non-essential
goods
that's the cheap plastic [ __ ] we don't
need
and so we're spending money on on these
things that well why well I was I was
racking up debt spending money I didn't
have right to buy things I didn't need
to impress people I didn't know or
didn't like and that's the situation you
were in you liked one person and she's
like well I don't date broke people but
you went from broke to broke in in a way
because that snowballed into this this
entire series of events where you ended
up living in a Walmart parking lot
because you were living up to someone
else's expectations and you know what
man you said something true to impress
people
I don't even know you know I impressed
someone that I like I can't even
remember her last name today doesn't
even know what she looks like today she
can come up to me today I bought her a
purse and I don't even know I can't even
recognize her Wow and I got into debt
and I paid interest on her and I
couldn't even identify who she is today
and to me I'm like man we so often this
younger generation we so much want to
impress and there's a study that shows
out we don't buy now this generation is
not buying to impress their friends
they're buying to impress their friends
on social media right that they've never
met no and I'm like we're getting into
debt to impress me on social media to
get a double like to get a heart and you
don't know me right if you get into
trouble financially I'm not paying your
bills but you got a light yeah good luck
good luck spending those lights come on
man you know in your book I always skip
the introduction of the foreword to
books I read your book a few months ago
good and thank you that means a lot yeah
and as I was going through it I'm like
why don't they teach college kids this
information I mean I didn't finish
college but like I wish I would have
been handed this information in high
school at some point in time and then
today I was back in the green room I was
flipping through I opened up to the
foreword and I think the first paragraph
is the four worth written by Dave Ramsey
and and he was like hey these are the
things that they should actually be
teaching in college and however seeing
this and why aren't we empowering the
youth to make responsible decisions with
their money it seems to me that we're
doing the opposite right now oh yeah
we're definitely doing opposite you know
America gets mad at me when I say this
is because it's funny how America
rewards us to be in debt and then they
penalize us for not being in debt what I
mean you get an 800 credit score if you
have a lot of stuff on your credit
report but then you have a zero credit
score if you're completely debt free
like myself and so we're teaching
America to consume and to keep money
flowing and to stay into debt rather
than teaching them to have freedom to
have
life and to be a blessing and a giver so
we have to but you know what our team
Dave Ramsey myself
Rachel Hogan you know we actually do
have a curriculum and that is out in a
lot of high schools one out of three
high schools have it about about I say
about 10% colleges have it colleges are
kind of tripping right now but anyways
this is something that I wish that I had
when I was in high school because you
know my parents are grew up in the
spiritual background my dad is a
full-time pastor they taught me
everything from a spiritual perspective
high schools taught me how to read write
add and process information but no one
told me how to do life how to budget
what's the debit car what is a credit
card what is a credit score what is
wealth what is the true definition of
wealth how do you just do the things
that you just need to do not get the
things that you want to do and so you
know I'm on a mission traveling the
world helping parents strengthen their
kids and touching all Millennials and
just young people and helping them avoid
the mistakes that I've made all of us
have made and I gotta say this cuz I
love these guys when I see y'all's
Netflix I went on my social media and I
say yo all of you all need to watch this
every I believe every young person who's
a millennial or in high school needs to
hear you all's message because if I
would have heard you all's message now I
wouldn't be living in a box but I would
definitely be living a lot better now
because of what you all are teaching
well you know I think you know we talk
about minimalism you talk about debt and
finances but really the three of us we
have the same common goal man we want
people to stop well a I'm acting on
every single impulse and be
understanding that acting on those
impulses how they can just lead us down
a path that we don't want to be down one
of the things that really stands out to
me in your book is how you talk about
how debt is normalized and and you know
these eighteen year old kids that are
graduating high school maybe they're
going to college maybe they're not but
there are corporations out there
targeting people who are for all intents
and purposes naive who they can take
advantage of to to get into massive
heaps of debt and own them years and
years later so you found yourself in
tens of thousands of dollars worth of
debt right
talk a little bit about because I know
we all know how to get into debt right
but not all of us know how to get out of
that yeah so talk about how you were
able to kind of dig yourself out of that
hole yeah it's sort of very first thing
for me was my mind before I can even
touch anything comes when it comes to
the finances to the practical to
finances
I had to shift the way I was thinking
and really understand like hey I don't
need this stuff I need to stop trying to
impress my peers if people don't like me
for who I am they don't need to be in my
life period and in three as a man I need
to be preparing myself for my family for
my future to leave an inheritance to my
children's children so I had to shift my
whole mindset to be like you know what
I'm going to do this thing right so that
was a very first thing then the second
thing I had to get some practical skills
and so I literally dipped Dave Ramsey's
baby says my mentor that's how I got out
of debt you know baby step number one
set aside a thousand dollars for an
emergency then I just went into baby set
number two and I just lined up my debt
from smallest to largest I got an extra
job and here's the trip y'all gonna
laugh just don't laugh too hard my very
first job can y'all guess what my very
first job was what would you if you had
to guess what was my very first job I
mean clearly a Calvin Klein model I
liked him mine was bagging groceries so
I'm gonna go with that bagging groceries
both of y'all around I owed money bill
collectors will call him me my very
first job was a bill collector oh that's
great I own Citibank I can say this I
owe Citibank and we collect it from
Citibank so I'm at the computer names
are popping up and I'm sweating please
let my name come up so I was a bill
collector so I promise you the very
first bill thankfully that was in my
baby cell was Capital One
my very first paycheck I have paid that
one off and I walked into the world here
I'm a grown man now what's up Mary so I
was a bill collector and then at night
time on my wash cars and so I literally
just started getting all that money in I
got on a budget and I literally told my
friends hey I can't go out we live in
California so we're right next to Mexico
so you know when you 18 you
crazy stuff you want to go to Mexico and
so I would tell him not we ain't going
to Mexico tonight Braga
I got a stacked his money like I said
this my bro it's Mexico I'm like Mexico
in way and I just got really intense
about getting out of debt because I
didn't want to go back there I didn't
want to go back to acting like I have
the money when I really do not have the
money you know what I love about this is
that this is very practical it's not
like this magic bullet answer no it
sounds to me like it was it was a lot of
hard work to get out and that's Josh and
I we talked about that a lot how you
know simple isn't necessarily easy yes
easy is to get into debt to go with the
flow and then eventually you know you
end up with the waterfall and regretting
it right um but but yes - to simplify
your life to get out of debt it takes a
lot of work it takes a plan and I'll
tell you man anyone out there right now
in this this crowd or listening to this
podcast who is struggling with finances
you've got to start with a budget like
that is by far the number one thing
since we're on the road with Anthony and
Chris and Rachel I've been like you know
going over all these financial books and
there's one very common thing through
every book it is start with a budget so
now I have like a little mentoring a
side business that I have where I'll
take on some some mentoring students and
stuff and the students will come to me
and they they'll talk about their money
problems yeah
and that might be ten minutes into the
call and I'm like I'm happy to spend
this whole hour with you but have a
budget and then let's talk about your
money problems after you come up with a
budget and it was like this is like you
don't have a money problem if you have a
budget problem you have the budget right
exactly then we'll talk about the money
yeah and it's it's just um I had no idea
how because I went on the budget before
when I was trying to get out of debt
right and then you know as soon as I was
out of debt I just kind of slacked off a
little bit on the budget and after going
through these books I'm talking to
Mariah because we live in LA now and
it's a little bit more expensive to live
in LA the Montana clearly yeah and I'm
like I'm like you know what we were
doing so much better than our finances
in Montana now that we're living in that
light like we need to come up with a
budget so we've been doing this for the
last couple months
it meant every time that I might go to
the corner store I want to buy like
sparkling water
something and it cost me three bucks and
the thought of going in the sorbonne is
paying the $3.00 and then going into my
every dollar app to put in the $3.00 I
spent it's not worth the hassle of
messing with my budget so just having
that one little tool it will put your
spending into perspective yeah and to
keep this in mind I had the opportunity
when y'all hit the road with Chris Hogan
he can definitely eat this one and some
more but I've had the opportunity to
wear for my mentors and millionaires and
and I've asked them all the same thing
how did you get there how did you do it
what do you what is one tip would you
give me to be a millionaire and none of
them really knew at the time and I was
connected with Dave and stuff like that
and all of them said have a budget well
let me ask you this in that same vein we
we actually go to the other side instead
of having a budget we're not concerned
about the budget we're concerned about
our credit score now you alluded to this
a moment ago and one of the things that
you you you you said in your book you
talked about the FICO score right I love
that breakdown of wood yeah it's funny
we I was I was doing a YouTube video and
talking about the three people who'd be
on the robots and I brought your book up
and I read that little excerpt in there
about the FICO score and the person who
commented was like this Anthony guys
clearly naive everyone needs to have a
great credit score I'm naive in yeah why
are they wrong well here's the thing man
I don't have a credit score and and this
is why it's because I said this earlier
that a credit score it literally only
tells you how much debt you have how
often you're paying back you're dead
what kind of debt you have what's the
likelihood of you getting more debt so
when we look at a credit score our
credit score rewards us for debt and
that it's not freedom so if you have an
800 credit score it just simply means
you love if you have a zero credit score
it means that you love cash and you're
patient to buy the things with your
money and so I'm not saying that a
credit score is you're just a horrible
individual for me and my house what I
believe is I'm going
to pay for everything and I'm going to
own everything that I have not the banks
and so for an example a lot of people
say well you have to have a credit score
to buy a house well you don't I just
built my dream home
it's a little bit bigger than what you
know that yeah anyways we don't judge
men okay thank you so much no we don't
know how shame day we go yes so I built
my dream home it's a nice house anyways
you can you use every single piece of a
man don't put don't sell yourself short
no I mean but no listen I was building
my house while watching you all show and
say you know what I went back to my
architect scratch it all let's do this
thing again because I don't need it what
dining room it's just me bro do I really
need a dining room No
so um really I I did the right thing but
what I'm saying is this I didn't need a
credit score see my there's this thing
called underwriting and what they
manually will underwrite your mortgage
payment cuz I did finance my home I put
down 50% i financed the other 50% for 10
years and and it's all literally a fixed
rate and so my goal is paid off in five
because I don't like debt and that's the
only thing that we say okay we're cool
with but I don't need a credit score for
that then a lot of people said well you
need a credit score for a newer rental
company well I rented a car to drive up
here today to come be with you all and I
did it with my debit card here's the
downfall that a lot of people say
without a credit score you're gonna move
slow and absolutely right but you know
what I don't have a problem with moving
slow I Drive a car right now that's 100
and has 170 thousand miles on it it
works and it is beautiful and whoever I
get married she's gonna deal with it
because the engines knocking a little
bit but it's paid for and at least we
knocking on our front door of the house
you know and so a credit score no it is
it's not needed I've never ran into a
situation to where I couldn't get what I
wanted because I didn't have a credit
score now are there certain people who
will not finance you oh absolutely but
why do you need financing if you're
gonna do everything cash all of my
mentors are completely debt free and I
have mentors who are millionaires and I
have mentors who are just making six
figures and now also have mentors who
are pastors who are not making six
figures and none of
have a credit score but I do tell you I
can't tell you there's one thing that
all of them have is a peace of mind in
knowing that you know what I own every
single thing that I have and if I can't
pay for it cash I'm gonna wait until I
can I love that uh I think was your day
that was good thank you so much well
what you were saying it reminds me of
what you were talking about the book
what your dad said content people they
don't have the best of things but they
do make the best of things and it's the
truth man well we're here for you all
tonight so let's line up and let's let's
do some questions money and minimalism
sort of everything in between we'll
start over here thank you
howdy oh man she ran to the mic remind
me your name she was that our VIP event
there were folks up here that spent
really good money to give Ryan a hug
before the before the event yadi yadi I
didn't want to give me a hug she's right
reviving I got you I'm Haley Haley where
you from I am originally from Auburn but
I've been in Birmingham for about six
years now so okay well thanks for being
here okay I don't like football so but
and I didn't spend my money to come here
my parents gifted this experience to me
so thank you to them for that but my
question does have to do with money so
and for all of you what kind of advice
do you have for someone who has student
loan debt but is trying to build their
own dreams so I was recently in a
position where I had a really cushy job
it was in my career field and it was
cushy I was happy I was putting a lot of
money towards my student loan debt I was
like I can do this I'm paying them off
I was then put in a position where I had
to quit that job unfortunately I dealt
with some harassment at work and had to
quit but it's
everything happens for a reason and so
that has pushed me to really think about
things and I am in a position where I
had saved up money I was you know as
much money as I'm putting into my
student loans I need to build a safety
net so I do have a decent amount put
back that I was gonna use to pay off my
student loans but I'm in a position now
where I want to quit building other
people's dreams and I want to build my
own so what kind of advice do you have
in terms of I'm a creative person I'm a
photographer I have the equipment I need
how do I strike a balance between paying
off my debts and building my dreams well
I think Anthony will probably have a
much better answer than I would but I'm
just thinking about let's say you have
$10,000 worth of debt but you also have
$10,000 in the bank this is a round
number and and you wouldn't do the same
thing you wouldn't if you had if you
were debt-free today you wouldn't go out
and borrow $10,000 just to put it in the
bank to focus on your dreams you pay off
that debt and you would untether from
feeling deaf but you would feel that
free I think Anthony is on board he's
he's signaling for those of you
listening at home yeah it's funny
because I had I had a bunch of debt was
a bunch of student debt and this
actually is probably not the best move
but but this is how aggressive I was
towards the debt and tell and tell
everyone here and at home what a bad
decision this was but I had a very small
wall when I say very small about if I
cleared out my 401k I could get that
twenty thousand bucks to pay off that
twenty thousand dollars in student debt
and I made that decision I paid a ton of
fees but but my point is is that you're
in a better spot than I was you've got
money that you're not gonna pay a bunch
of taxes on when you when you take out
and you could pay off that student debt
but I mean that's how passionate I was
about paying off my debt as I was like
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna incur
more interest charges over the next you
know ten years then I'm gonna make off
of this 401k which again probably was
not the best call but I was I was that
aggressive towards attacking my debt
yeah so before I get to you that was a
horrible call
this before y'all podcast this and it's
anyway um so I I gotta ask two questions
gotta make sure I just give you the
practical how old are you I'm 23
oh my gosh and then and then not that's
probably too much money
i'ma assume it's 2 person or someone
asked that question so here's your boat
ok how much money do you have in your
savings about $10,000 how much how many
student loans do you have um about
$15,000 okay cool so let me just say
this right now up front I like you
you're young you need to take $9,000 out
okay leave a thousand dollars in your
emergency fund okay $9,000 goes towards
your student loans that's gonna bring
you down to six thousand dollars left
less as far as much you have left over
and here's why student loans are
occurring interest every single day
daily and so what I want you to do is
knock that stuff down right now so in
your future you're not paying that stuff
back you're 23 years old you are just
bright you are you are determined to
become successful but I also want to
heard you say something else that I hear
a lot earnest young people in special
Millennials I'm tired of building
somebody else's dreams I want to build
my own your young build someone else's
dream right now wow you're building your
own because you need to have some income
coming in to going ahead and knock off
your debt build your funds but by the
time you turn 25 you can start working
full-time on yours so this is what I
want to do give me your information
before we leave and I'm gonna send you
to Christy writes business boutique
seminar in Nashville Tennessee and she's
gonna show you how you can work while
building your dreams from home to
eventually transfer from working to
building but pay off your student loans
I promise you it will be worth it
because now you have six thousand
dollars you can have that paid off by
the end of this year you're 24 debt free
single the brothers are coming for you
she made that loud and clear y'all do we
have any brothers
that would be my suggesting to the
building your dreams sometimes you can
build your dreams and your dreams can be
can correspond with other people's Dre
you go right now I mean I'm the most
introverted person you've ever met I
spend 90% of my time alone I know does
it seem like that because every time I'm
in front of I'm in front of a crowd of
people and I'm with Ryan whenever you
see me but it requires a team of people
for us to be on the same page to do what
we're doing we've got Jordan over here
one of the reasons we're working with
Jordan now he's doing all the Jordan
yeah oh wow he is the new film maker on
the minimalists team and yeah and what
we're there one of the reasons that we
decided to work with him is because he
he realized like I don't need all the
fanciest equipment I don't need to spend
all this money in order to make
something meaningful
I can go give him you know uh well I
could give him a hundred thousand dollar
camera and a ten thousand dollar camera
it depends on what the person behind the
camera is actually doing if you gave me
the hundred thousand dollar camera your
pride to end up with a broken camera and
the point is that that you don't need
you you what you need right now at your
age is some creative constraints those
constraints are going to help build your
creativity and they're gonna make you a
better stronger person because of it
definitely thank you thank you guys yes
yeah she's single
I do want to throw in the caveat we had
a we had a little event before this with
the people who spent a little bit more
money to sit up front but uh we we were
talking about we were talking about me
paying off my debt and I just want to
say dude like it was after I paid off
all my debt that I found Total Money
Makeover and I found you in Rachel and
Chris and I wish I would have started
with that recipe because yeah I
definitely didn't have the rest best
recipe going into a pan off my dad
alright well this is the shortest
podcast ever howdy
what's your name Annabeth were you from
I mean Haley are kind of switched I'm
from Birmingham but I live in Auburn
welcome tonight what's your question I
want to know how you can go to college
with no money Anthony you can't go to
college with no money you can't go to
college without borrowing money how do
you do that I like you yes I was about
to say well you got that someone got to
pay so the key thing is is it for you is
it for someone else for me how old are
you well I'm gonna I'm in college now
okay I'm at Auburn but I'm 22 22 gonna
be a fifth year still there okay great
so I'm gonna give you this tip this is
what I give everyone if you have college
students in school right now if you know
anyone go into college or a podcast
listeners if you're listening here the
three things that I really want you to
do right now the very first thing for
you 22 in school right now the very
first one is my skali calm my SCH o LLY
calm the number one scholarship tool
because they specialized they're gonna
ask you a lot of personal questions
okay and what they're gonna do is
they're gonna send you this long list of
scholarships and grants are available
for your age bracket for your career
field and that's what's the chances of
you actually getting it the next one is
a book called the ultimate scholarship
book look for the current year that is
like my secret if you're looking for
some extra scholarships Amazon it's like
50 bucks you always get the digital
version because if
get the digital version then you can go
in there every single year and see
what's updated okay
then here's the next tip I will go to
every single small business in your
local community because they're always
giving away scholarships and that is so
key go to your Chamber of Commerce go to
your local mom-and-pop shops go
somewhere that because they got to have
some write-offs and so they're always
looking to bless single mothers or you
know adults who want to go back to
school and better their lives or kids
who are graduated from high school and
so I give you those three things and I
say this it works lobbyists are ours
crazy
we're here sit here's a stat 1.7 billion
dollars worth of scholarships and grants
go away every single year okay and the
problem is that I did the research out
of the one point seven billion dollars
900 million of those are your
scholarships a thousand and less so
apply for every single 501 thousand
dollar scholarship I mentor a group of
kids who are it's a hundred of them
every single year a hundred percent of
them go to school debt-free and my
number one student raised eighty eight
thousand dollars just offer those three
things it's always about your
determination if you are determined to
finish school debt-free it's never about
the lack of your abilities only about
the lack of your determination he was
determined to get out of debt he made a
bad decision to use the 401k so we want
that kind of determination but we just
want to make the smart decisions behind
it and grants and scholarships and
working is the main three things and
here's the last tip I'll give you them
to be quiet let my brother's tall black
people we can talk a lot anyways yep
there's nothing wrong with moving slow
okay so if you have to slow down settle
for taking four classes a semester maybe
take two classes a semester there's
nothing wrong with that it's not about
how you start it's about how you finish
and it's not a matter of when you finish
it's just how you finish the average
student is graduating with $37,000 in
student loan debt if it takes you six
years to be debt-free compared to four
years nearly $40,000 in debt I'm taking
the extra two years yeah I think that's
great at the I'm the wrong person to ask
about this because I didn't graduate
college but I still had student debt so
I was doing the exact opposite of what
you were recognizing although if I were
going back now if I had a reason to go
to college I tell you what I would do
besides all the beautiful advice you
just got there is I would find someone
who graduated debt-free or one of those
hundred students or maybe ten of those
hundred students a year I would sit down
with them and say all right tell me how
you actually did it give me your recipe
because if I have a template I know that
I can follow that template and with a
recipe you know I can I could change a
few ingredients to suit my taste but if
I get enough recipes from enough people
I can build my own recipe to get through
college debt-free yeah the one of the
mistakes that then Anthony talks about
in this book is is you have to have a
plan if you are going throughout your
college career without a plan then you
are setting yourself up for overall door
hurt when you graduate the other thing
that really helped me out man is the
scholarship thing that when I was going
to school when I was going to college
that sounded like such a daunting task
for me like writing essays and
questionnaires and sending emails but
after reading your book I didn't realize
like after you get that template after
that first template you get put together
for that scholarship you could just
reuse that same template over and over
so that first that first thing that you
submit it's going to take a lot of work
and a lot of time to make it look nice
and pretty and then submit it but once
you have that template you could repeat
that over and over again and bust out a
ton of submissions you know you know
what's funny about that is I think one
of the reasons it seems so daunting it
because it seemed as soon as you said
I'm like that's why I didn't ever apply
for scholarships because we think of the
big scholarships I want the $20,000
scholarship right and that's like trying
to make the half-court shot when you
have all these layups right there in
front of you have a two hundred fifty
five hundred dollars scholarship seven
hundred dollar scholarship all these
scholarships that are out there and
available you don't have to go for the
the twenty thousand dollar thing that
everyone's competing for when these
others out here that no one is competing
for
know this your so go ahead I was just
gonna make a smartass comment so you go
with yours
yeah Maz won't be that you know which is
so confusing to me because I hear that
all the time that's a lot of work now
wait a minute so let's just do the math
if you apply if you spend one hour just
one hour and you apply for a $500
scholarship let's say you apply for ten
of them and you only get one in that one
hour right you made $500 if you go to
work are you gonna make $500 and one
hour so it's like for me when I tell
kids like man look at it from a
different angle like if you come home
every single day you just spend an hour
hour and a half every single day and you
apply for ten to fifteen scholarships
and let's say you only get one let's
just be real if you don't get none that
day but then on the next day let's say
you apply every single day for five days
for five days you 16 years old and you
only get one scholarship out of the
whole week you made five hundred dollars
in one week would you make five hundred
dollars in a month as a 16 year old no
so it's always about I say look look at
the perspective work hard go after that
thing if you get told no today you make
it told yes tomorrow but if you get no
tote no no no no no then you get that
one yes it is so worth it especially for
a 22 year old who's in college trying to
better your future your future is so
bright because you want to get the
education but you want to get it right
so you can graduate get into your career
field follow what they're teaching stack
your money get married have some kids
and just do it right if that's the path
you want the things she was saying are
you saying you're not single thank you
for your question appreciate I
all right before we move on to this next
question here Ryan do you know what time
it is is it time already for the
lightning round we answer questions from
social media
it is indeed time for our lightning
round so here's a week we try to do when
our normal studio podcast Anthony what
we do is we we someone gives us a
question and then we give them a pithy
answer that we can like share and 140
characters on Twitter but because this
is a live event what we'll do is we'll
just ramble on a bit until eventually we
come up with something that's tweetable
so we'll still ramble on a bit it's time
for the lightning round if you want to
follow along at home I think by the way
Jess I think she is is live tweeting the
event ladies and gentlemen jessica lynn
williams yeah speaking of having a great
team she is she helps keep all of our
social media look looking beautiful so
thank you for that Jess I think she's
live tweeting from the event we're at
the minimalists on all the social media
is if you want to follow along
howdy what's your name what's your
question I'll hear from Pete well thank
you for making the drive from
Mississippi okay so how do you base
buying things sorry how do you base
buying things of value when you're in
debt for instance I enrolled in
financial piece in January that costs
money I bought books on minimalism those
cost money how do you how do you you
know base when it's a good value when
you're in debt sure I mean as long as
you're buying our books it's fine no
actually it's not in fact I encourage
people do the opposite I often courage
you to go to your local library and try
to check out if these resources are
available for free I certainly encourage
you to take advantage of the resources
when they are free now Ryan and I
certainly aren't against spending money
I think we all and we're not against
money either I think it's a it's a
common misconception that that people
who are become minimalist have to live
these lives of poverty or we are against
the money problems there you go yeah I'm
not against against money I'm against
money problems
that's that's I'm still in that pit the
answer there we go you can tweet that oh
yeah you all right I'm just gonna say
this this is not a judgment this is just
it is what it is you cannot spend your
way out of debt that is absolutely true
you know this
that's just tweet that's super tweeter
that's my that's my answer
but but what I mean by that is yes maybe
there's a class a financial class here
to sign up for maybe there is a book
that wasn't available at the library and
you wouldn't it wouldn't had to buy I
mean I'm not saying that the purchase is
that you have made have been totally you
know irresponsible but yes there's a
certain point where you have to come up
with that budget and you have to work
that budget and yes stop buying more
things that you think you're gonna help
you get out of debt because yes you
cannot spend your way out of that yeah
that's like I totally agree with that it
it bothers me when I hear a lot of
people said well you know I want to
learn how to get out of debt so I bought
Dave's book I bought this book about
that book I did this I did this I went
to this seminar I went to this thing on
how to build wealth no no you cannot
spend your way out of debt what you do
is you have to spend your money on your
debt then once you get out of debt then
you need to spend your money on your
savings to prepare for your future so
without recommend is right now you did
FPU you bought a great book I don't mean
to be rude but stop and just just get
amazing for example if you don't mind us
asking how much did are you in sixty
four thousand okay cool sixty four
thousand dollars that's a lot of money
you have a job cool great and you don't
have a job and you're buying stuff oh
you have a husband so you have a job by
the way of your husband I got youth I'm
praying for your husband so what I would
recommend yeah I feel so sorry for you
trying to get out of debt she's spending
yo money
what I recommend both of y'all have to
get on the same page and like he said
get on a budget and just spend your
money on your debt and just for season
I've heard people in worse situations
sixty four thousand dollars in a matter
of two years you can get out of that and
at you Laos age bracket man that future
is so bright from there just one more
all we are not yep about 28 right 30 32
you're gonna get that hug you ask for me
I'm serious what 30 to me 54 next week
54 you do not look like you thanks this
is jeans yes yes no that that's that is
one thing with a budget like you know
youn your husband got to have a
conversation come up with a budget in
yeah and support one another through
this this way out of debt this path out
of that when's the last time y'all went
out on a date tonight great date I would
say you get spend your money on one more
thing go out on a date and bring a pen
and paper and put your vision for you
also on that paper and then get another
piece of paper and do a budget and make
sure that your vision for your life and
your budget is congruent and working
together so don't go to an expensive
restaurant go to Red Lobster buy some
biscuits we're gonna do one more money
question then we're gonna move over to
this microphone here in a little bit so
if you saw there other people I can't
tell if there's a line if you want to
migrate well we'll figure it all out
here on the back end howdy what's your
name where you from my name is Erin I'm
from Abilene Texas well thank you for
being here so I guess my question is
will be a tough one I hope I hope I just
think it might be so 18 year old Erin
decided it was smart to go to a private
school and to get a degree in youth
ministry and now I'm trying to figure
out what to do with a substantial
private school debt off of you know
service industry hey is there something
you want to do with the degree that you
have earned or you decided that you go
want to do something with that degree my
degree is youth ministry and graphic
design and so I mean I want to be
involved in ministry I spent four years
in the youth camping industry teaching
outdoor education I'm a school teacher
now no it's kind of open to where God
leads me in the ministry field but just
really wanting to get rid of that debt
but also looking down being like man
they you know charge this to pay youth
minister almost nothing yeah yeah so how
much how much debt you have right now I
think whenever I look at all the
interests and stuff on there I'm sitting
right around 100,000 okay six figures
worth a day and at a few percent from my
dad professor how much money you're
earning right now I'm a year I'm a
school teacher I'm earning in the
mid-40s okay okay so this isn't
impossible it's not like you don't have
any income right you just need more
income I could tell you one thing that I
did certainly wasn't sexy
I delivered pizzas for a while that's
because uber wasn't and lyft weren't
available at the time I I'm pretty sure
I would have done that however they that
was something I had to do and I was I
had a corporate job and I was in debt
I'm like what am i I need to get rid of
this as soon as possible because what
you're talking about right now is you
want to untether from your past and
right now you're unable to untether from
that past because you you may end up
doing something with with this degree
but you're not gonna do anything with
the debt right the debt it's all a sunk
cost and you wish you wouldn't have gone
into it but we can wish all day now it's
time we have to do something about it
right and so when I when I look at
someone who's in your situation you
don't just have a debt problem you have
a bit of an income problem and that
means you don't have I mean I could live
fine off $40,000 a year it wouldn't be
in Los Angeles
but I remember when I first left the
corporate world in Dayton Ohio I was
more financially secure that year I took
about a 90% of a hiatus about 90 percent
pay
I was making $23,000 a year in Dayton
Ohio and I was more financially secure
that year but the reason being is I
didn't have these heaps of debt and I
spent all of my time attacking that debt
so that I didn't have to be tethered to
a life I no longer wanted to lead man I
am I'm thinking to myself like if
because I didn't do the traditional
college route I certain school 25 years
old cuz work paid for it I was like oh
I'd be stupid not to go for it pays for
it and then two years later they stopped
paying for it no I'd be stupid to drop
out so I'm gonna rack up some debt
finishing school anyway if I was 18
years old going into it I would
certainly I would probably tell my thing
myself things like dude this is this is
a college experience it happens only
once in your life I want to make sure
that I'm gonna like go to the school I
want to go to I'm gonna live and the
place I want to live I'm I deserve to
have all of this this great college
experience and I think that everyone out
there deserves to enjoy their college
experience but we have to be careful
with that that word deserve I know this
is an answering your question but here's
what I'll say when we do fall into that
mode and we do tell ourselves we deserve
it and we spent four years racking up
huge amounts of that here's my pity
answer spending four years of careless
spending will force you into eight years
of careful budgeting so so right now
you're at you're at that you're at that
point man like you have made this bet
that you have to land which is okay like
you your this is not undoable you're
super young and you've got many many
years ahead of you in it but what it is
gonna take you years to get out of this
of careful careful budgeting and it's
and it is paying for that four years of
careless spending that you had but the
good news is is that yes if you come up
with a plan you will absolutely be able
to you have to work that plan though and
it's gonna be tough at first you might
have to do some uber driving on the
weekends you might have to deliver some
pizzas I wonder what the going rate is
for a pizza driver now probably not as
much as an uber uber drivers make tips
now too so I mean you know I was in this
one one Oberer and this guy was just
hustling he was like do you need hand
sanitizer you need a charger for your
eyes
you hear I'm selling these little things
for you know fifty cents or whatever and
I'm not tell you to take it to that
extreme but he was making it work like
I'm like hey man why you said all this
stuff he's like credit card day Anthony
save us here man you know y'all y'all
hitting it on man you know first thing
is men want to commend you for for
having a heart for ministry because our
young people do need positive more
positive role models in the world and I
said it because man I went to seminary
school to be a youth minister as well
and I was a youth pastor for 13 years so
on a practical side what I would tell
you is do exactly what they're saying
figure out that way and maybe look into
this as well figure out how to use your
degree to build your shovel and your
shovel is your income so right now maybe
figure out since you have a heart for
you to ministry on how to become very
well known you speaker youth speakers do
make good money traveling around the
world and so if you can really figure
out your message and take your message
into schools colleges churches that
could be some extra income as a school
teacher your shell will just went from
forty thousand to now maybe eighty
thousand instead of for it taking it
youth for so loan to get out I really
believe you can do it within three years
if you get focused and built that shovel
up Anthony
one other thing he mentioned also
graphic design right come on
and so you've got you've got so it
depends you may be part of it is you you
want to speak to the youth but speaking
is it the only way to speak right and I
mean you look now when we have just so
we have Jordan or we have podcast Sean
hiding in the shadows somewhere ladies
and gentlemen podcast Sean they're all
helping us speak to people via these
different mediums and and so one thing
that you can do is is via graphic design
via design is communicate the way you're
trying to communicate and there are
plenty of people who make additional
money you know Jordan was a is
constantly Instagram hustling to to make
some more money on the side so it's
something you can do for sure and
he ain't cheap either I know I got my
garnet back I'm paying him a lot of
money right now
and Aaron it's IIIi agree with you man
it probably isn't gonna take eight years
but uh but but it you know for as much
time as it took you to get into that
that it's gonna take you some time to
get out of it but brother you got it man
keep asking the right questions and work
your plan like you will get out of it
maybe maybe the pippi answer there is it
didn't take you a day to get into debt
and it's good not gonna take you a day
to get out of debt perfect that's the
answer
Thank You Aaron Thanks all right so if
you're listening at home we'd love to
hear what you have to say so if you have
a comment or a tip about money or
minimalism give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm it's my favorite part
of the show we air our favorite comments
and tips and then later we just go back
and rewrite the answers and pretend
they're our own Ryan now we usually each
week I'll say something like PS we've
got two we've got one more question but
we have more than one question right now
and so our podcast is 100% advertisement
free because advertisements Birmingham
can do better than that this don't just
yell suck ass they showed you how let's
try this again this podcast is a hundred
percent advertisement free because
advertisements you're damn right they do
that's good and so instead of peddling
mattresses and other things that we may
not believe in we ask for support from
our audience so we do something called
patreon and we ever every week we do
something called a a PostScript episode
it's a bonus episode we also do some
monthly live streams for our patreon
supporters and a bunch of other really
cool things and Jordans got a bunch of
really cool ideas for new video
creations just for our patreon
supporters yeah so we're going to
tonight we're going to dive into a
postscript episode live in front of this
audience here and we'll get to as many
questions as we can before we are
dragged off the stage later
tonight but we've got some time so let's
dive into this show this would be a
really good time for the folks listen to
this at home Shawn to just insert a nice
snippet of that patreon episode that we
just did and for folks at home who want
to support the podcast you can just go
to the minimalists comm slash support
and you can find all of our past
PostScript episodes and all the good
stuff we give all of our supporters
thank you for giving us your support
because it keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free so grateful and I
think the one the snippet they're
probably gonna put in there is just you
saying you cannot afford a house that
was dope I was gonna go somewhere with
that but I won't
it's inappropriate my suggestion as a
young person is that I don't agree with
investing into my future and my present
is rocky so what I want to do is get my
present solid then build on top of that
okay so I would say I would say get out
of debt first
stack that emergency fund then start
building for your future because why
build for your future when you may have
to spend a lot of money to get out of
debt right now or something happens
right now so that's what I highly
recommend because study shows that your
age bracket in debt we're only going to
invest about maybe two to three percent
of our income but if we're out of debt
we're going to invest close to ten to
fifteen percent so you will catch up in
time if you have that much freedom on
your paycheck you know your income
[Music]
anyway let's move on to our added value
segment this is we're talking about
something that has added value to our
lives recently we usually like to make
this like City centric when we're in a
city we didn't get a chance to enjoy
your city yeah but if you have tomorrow
we're gonna find the best coffee shop in
town so please tweet us and let us know
what the best coffee shop is we're gonna
find it in the morning and we'll be
there so I can't give you something
local that has added value to my life
unless chipoltle a is local but Ryan
what does added value to your life
recently outside of Birmingham well I
mean since we have Anthony here like
got to recommend the five mistakes you
cannot afford to make in college but
here's the thing man is when when I can
pick up a book and I can read it in like
three hours like and get some very very
valuable information out of that that is
that's my type of book man it is it is a
it is a very nice very much very similar
to like Derrick servers anything you
want it's like just a small book packed
full of information if you aren't in
college but you got like kids in college
like I would highly recommend that they
read this book check it out from the
library you don't have to actually buy
him a copy especially you don't buy any
more books I'm giving you a hard time
but no it's it's it's amazing just
jam-packed full of awesome awesome
information on how you can go to college
debt-free you find Anthony O'Neal on all
the social is he's at Anthony O'Neal on
Twitter and Instagram will put links to
all the his information in the show
notes as well as far as things that add
value to my life recently wid Canyon
City opened the show would you think of
Paul there I accidentally stumbled
across his music last year and we've
become friends over the last years
because I think he's the best songwriter
out right now if you listen to the
lyrics on his most recent album I just
came out last year it's called
consolation in fact we did a podcast
episode with him last time he was out in
Los Angeles he's from Nashville and we
did an episode about hobbies and how
sometimes we try to turn our hobby into
our profession it ruins the thing we
love so you can go back and listen to
that I think it was episode 128 but what
I'd like to do tonight is have Paul come
out and perform his new single shadows
for you all y'all think about that
ladies and gentlemen can you city yeah
[Applause]
hello there and thank you such a
incredible I feel like I have no way to
rise up to the intro that just play your
music man it'll speak for itself
okay cool no it's I seriously like these
guys consistently challenge and inspire
me as do the people that come to these
and exhibit just in masses people that
are being intentional and really doing
something incredible so I think that
really ripples out in an amazing way so
thank you to the minimalists again
Anthony thank you to you guys and this
is a song called shadows this is about
Amazon Prime day
just kidding
he's really not I heard it never rains
in California every day just phasing out
our son
[Music]
maybe I should break away driver spin
swing
[Music]
it's good time for me to wait
[Music]
I had to find my way out of a badging
I came through the dust it's in my blood
good mercy our snitch
[Music]
years wasu
[Music]
from the shelves
[Music]
you are by the dogs he's scared of the
demons down it's time feline
[Music]
it's time your life
[Music]
they say a happy end as we leave
[Music]
is always gonna be another battle to
fight if you let the story go along all
the heroes
play
[Music]
all of you tonight
[Music]
you are two miles of dogs if you stare
is down it's time here
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
your head up from the shadow you're
almost through the night
[Music]
you optimize the dog you scared of UT
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's time to feel the light
[Music]
thanks so much Canyon City thank you
thank you so much thank you nameless
alright y'all real quick let's move on
the right here right now this is the
segment where we talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalist and
I'm really honored that you all decided
to spend this evening with us because
we're trying to do something special
right now I just turned 37 a few weeks
ago and I donated my 37th birthday
because Ryan and I are from a place
called Dayton Ohio it's the overdose
capital of America it is one of the
hungriest cities in America in fact the
second hungriest city for families with
children if there's about a million
people in the metro area roughly 200,000
people in the city if you go to the west
side of the city anywhere west of the
the river there is not a single grocery
store in all of Dayton Ohio on that on
the west side and the last one went out
of business about a decade ago so you
have access to food there but you don't
have access to nutrition you can buy
Cheetos at your local liquor store but
that's not gonna mean that you're living
your best life as a nourished healthy
human being we're trying to help out
with that so I donated my birthday I
encourage people to donate thirty seven
bucks so if you're listening to this at
home
donate thirty seven dollars for my
birthday instead of buying me a necktie
or a paperweight or something then
please just go to the minimalists comm
slash Dayton we're trying to help them
raise the last hundred thousand dollars
we need to build that grocery store to
provide food for families there and I'm
really grateful for you all because a
hundred percent of our profits we're
making from this entire tour Ryan and I
are gonna donate as well as some of our
own money a twenty thousand dollars of
our own money as well to the grocery so
every to everyone who bought a ticket
here tonight you contributed in some way
to help families who don't have access
to good food thank you for being here
thank you so much
[Applause]
and that's really what's going on right
here right now we're on the road with
Anthony and some other folks from the
Ramsey solutions team we're gonna be in
Louisville and and Nashville next couple
nights Anthony I want to acknowledge you
and say thank you so much for being with
us tonight brother I knew you were gonna
outshine us on stage too man
I knew it no not at all y'all did that
thing and you know what I must say this
i'ma donate as well to your birthday to
Dayton Ohio because yeah last time it's
been almost five years since we were in
Birmingham last hopefully it won't be
five years again before we make it back
here last time we were here we're in a
nice little coffee shop slash bookstore
someone else was here yes and so thank
you for coming thank you all for showing
up this time let's give it up for iron
City in theater yes
[Applause]
[Music]
this is like this is our aesthetic man
the brick we have so many places to take
pictures with the brick wall yeah
randomly if Ryan are walking around we
see a brick wall we just stop and take a
photo in front of it just in case
alright so if you leave here tonight
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for being
here
Birmingham thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
Mary Rose Coughlin Vernon Connecticut so
that's happened to me several times
where I've lost a great deal of money
and a pocket that I gave away or tipping
from the wrong pocket and I have money
traveling and I like to think that that
person needed the money more than I did
so whether you say God wanted them to
have it or the power of the universe and
you know they needed it that person
needed the money more than you did and
you're blessed to have opportunity to
share it with them hey Josh Ryan my
name's Christian and I'm calling from
Cleveland Ohio's on the Midwest guide
just like you guys you know I wanted to
call me with comment regarding the
anxiety podcast there is a person that
called I believe her name was cat and
she talked about having issues
indecisiveness and I kind of had my
guess is sort of a pity response to her
and it's you don't let perfect to be the
enemy of better you know I used to
recite that every time I was feeling
decisive I had a lot of problems with
that and I was always trying to make
things exactly the way I wanted them
before I moved on to the next part and I
found it that really kept me from
enjoying my life so that's really my
message to her and feel like it that
thing kind of helps me judge whether or
not I'm being indecisive and whether or
not my OCD is getting it away hey y'all
this is Emily Stewart from
South Carolina and I wanted to share a
tip so I've been a minimalist my entire
life even as a kid but I find myself
thinking that I don't have anything to
get rid of because I'm a minimalist so I
came up with a game with myself that
kind of helped me to keep cleaning
things out I often shop at Trader Joe's
in all these and I bring my own bags but
sometimes I forget and end up having to
grab the paper bags at checkout so my
new rule for myself is every time I do
this I have to fill up the paper bags
with things from my home to give away or
sell so although forgetting my own bags
isn't good for the environment it turned
into a great way to consistently clear
out and help keep it fun for me and
fresh even though I am have been a
minimalist for so long and minimalists